[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today we will try to understand the
mathematics behind general relativity
to do this we will gradually build all
the mathematical tools
essential to general relativity to avoid
overloading with content this series
will be split into eight
episodes in which we will define each
notion one by one
and that will be published in
independent videos the calculations and
equations will be shown
hoping that everything remains
understandable and intuitive
each video will start with a theoretical
explanation
followed by one or several concrete
examples to see how the concepts apply
in this series we will reconstruct each
notion
starting from scratch it is therefore
essential that we forget everything
all the notions that we think we know to
start from a blank slate
in front of us a sheet of paper on which
is traced a curve
[Music]
this sheet of paper is an image to
represent the structure of our universe
space-time space-time has four
dimensions
but to simplify only two of these
dimensions will be represented
the curve that is drawn on the surface
describes an object
for example an apple this curve
is what we call its world line we will
try to interpret this world line
to start off with we slice the world
line into small regular intervals
choosing one point as the origin we
number these intervals one by one
in this way we provide the curve with a
graduation
which allows us to transform it into a
series of consecutive points
these points can be interpreted as a
trajectory
the curve is no longer an object but a
movement
it represents the movement of the apple
through space-time we have invented
the concept of motion
these graduations along which the apple
moves will be called the apple's proper
time
the proper time of the apple is the time
that governs its internal evolution
in a way it is the time which would tick
on its own clock
as it passes the apple evolves and moves
through the dimensions of space-time
from now on proper time will be
indicated by the greek letter
tau
[Music]
now that the apple moves we want to
describe its position
as proper time goes by
to be able to locate a point
mathematically we will draw on our
surface
a coordinate system such a system is
represented as a grid
on the sheet of paper this grid has an
origin
a sort of zero point from which the grid
lines are counted one by one
in this way the position of the apple on
the surface is described by two numbers
called its coordinates
[Music]
it is important to understand that this
grid is arbitrary
it has no physical meaning it is simply
a convention that we choose
an abstract tool whose purpose is to
describe points using numbers
depending on what situation we analyze
some coordinate systems
will be more appropriate than others and
we will have the freedom to use
whichever we prefer
[Music]
let us illustrate all these concepts
with a concrete example
[Music]
imagine an apple falling vertically
towards the earth
and that we observe from a great
distance
as distant observers let's consider what
quantities we can measure
[Music]
first we can measure the distance
between the apple and the center of the
earth
as the apple falls vertically this
unique distance makes it possible to
locate the position of the apple
without ambiguity in addition
we can measure time in relation to our
clock
which will not necessarily flow at the
same pace as the apple's proper time
[Music]
in this way we can define two
coordinates which we call t for time
and r for altitude which allow us to
locate the apple in space time
relative to our perspective
[Music]
as its proper time goes by the apple
will move freely
and trace its trajectory within this
coordinate system
[Music]
we must be careful however to
distinguish our time
t which is a coordinate and the apple's
proper time
tau which represents the graduation
along its world line
[Music]
to understand let's take an example
say the apple passes through the point
whose coordinates are one second
and seven thousand kilometers this means
that when
our clock indicates one second we will
measure a distance
of 7000 kilometers between the apple and
the center of the planet
in space-time it is crucial to
understand that no
object is stationary indeed even if it
does not move in space
like an apple which remains motionless
on earth a body will always move through
time
as the apple progresses every second
towards the future
objects all have a speed in space time
the only thing that can change is how
this speed is distributed
between the coordinates of space and
[Music]
time
you